[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what's up everybody Welcome to the first
Hogwarts Legacy gameplay stream I'm
Chandler Wood Community manager here at
Avalanche software and we've got a lot
of really exciting stuff to show you
today but before we get into showing you
the game and gameplay I have a few
wonderful guests that that I need to
introduce you to First up we have our
community guest host
he brings you the latest and greatest in
Hogwarts Legacy content uh he's the
local Merlin conspiracy theorist uh
guilty as sharks one half of expecto go
James Whitehead uh thanks Joe uh yes
um I have James Whitehead I'll expect to
go I'll bring you guys the latest and
greatest in Hogwarts Legacy content and
I am one half of expect to go to where
they have my wife Sue uh represents that
other house so I'm excited to be here
and thank you uh Avalanche software for
inviting me I cannot wait to go over
this gameplay I just got to say that
welcome thank you for being here uh and
we've got two people from the studio
just two of the many people bringing
this thing together uh the magic of
Hogwarts Legacy game director Alan two
hello everyone and Senior environment
artist and Hogwarts expert Boston Madsen
so thank you for for taking time out of
your very busy schedules right now to
sit down with us to help us show
everybody gameplay so what we're going
to be showing you today first the
Character Creator because
you're it's your legacy and you have to
create yourself when you get into uh to
get into Hogwarts and bring your whole
authentic self to Hogwarts so we're
going to show you that character creator
then we're going to dive into a tour of
Hogwarts and it is
it's just a small tour of Hogwarts right
because Hogwarts is huge Hogwarts is
really big uh so we're going to be
showing you a little bit but it's still
a lot so
and finally ending up with uh combat a
little taste of combat a little taste of
how all that works
um just a little taste yeah so we're
excited to get there but again first and
foremost we need to get into this
character creator and James with you
here we wanted to let you create this
character so
Andrew who is going to be doing all of
our gameplay capture today
is going to be handing you the
controller
oh my gosh all right I won't break
anything
all right so what are we looking at
right here on this screen
um these are your presets so a lot like
uh other games there's there's some
initial settings that you can put up put
uh choose for your character that just
kind of get them into like the ballpark
of what you want to be who you want to
be and what you want to change oh man
and then once you're in that ballpark
all the other tabs let you dial that in
to be exactly who you want to be it's
our our goal with this is to make sure
that for anyone that fantasized about
bringing themselves to the school yeah
the very first time that they feel like
they have the options in order to
represent who they are and and
essentially bring themselves to Hogwarts
or whatever character they want to bring
to Hogwarts oh my God and options Galore
uh do you mind if I try to put myself in
here right quick this is all about you
okay okay okay okay all right all right
so oh okay yeah that's me that's me
we're here we're here that's me right
there all right so let's say that's the
one it's pretty close but let's like
let's look at let's look at everything
okay
play around with some of these options
like really all right so what are we
looking at with this option over here
with the tab I see face stuff yeah so a
lot of the different faces that you saw
in the in the previous screen all those
faces are are choices that you have here
so you can now you're just kind of
getting into the details in your face
shape and your skin color
um and then because we knew a lot of
people going right in are going to want
to right away even though it's an option
later in the game yeah you can collect
different types of glasses put them on
later we give you some options right up
front if you want to have glasses for
your character oh man oh my gosh look at
the structure of the faces with this wow
you guys thought of I have crazy I like
that I don't think my face is that
skinny but I think we'll go with that I
think we'll go that route uh and down
here is this those are your glasses
there
oh so we started we could go Harry
Potter if you want
oh man and this is just some of the
options I'm assuming yeah so through the
course of the game there's a lot there's
a lot of different uh options that
you'll keep unlocking okay so as part of
kind of like gear for the character
there's lots of different classes
there's even masses all kinds of things
uh over the course of the game console
Victorian era though yeah such a good
call that's a good call oh my gosh all
right so now oh my oh we can go Fleek on
this one with the hair
I spend a lot of time here just like
dreaming about my different characters
oh my gosh the pony
the thing I'm always amazed by whenever
I see any aspects of Hogwarts legacy's
character creator is just the texture
and like you even adding the bounce with
the hair moving around you know that
kind of looks like Hermione a little bit
I'm not afraid and we can just go can I
go like talks purple or green a little
bit absolutely
yo this is so cool oh I like that that
is cute
way back
I wanted uh silver tips so that was the
closest I got to eat the color but oh my
gosh this is so cool so you literally
can bring yourself like it's it's a
myriad of textures and different
hairstyles here all right so now we're
getting over here to uh play around with
some of those these are more subtle
options we've got freckles moles
um different things like uh when it
comes to your complexion like darker
eyes maybe like some shading on the
cheeks oh man you guys literally thought
of her
with this I do have a bit of fun with
that and then the scars are are one of
those options where
you know Harry had his own unique starts
yeah but you can come in with your star
options yeah
oh oh wow look at that I didn't even see
that
oh those are my favorite though the
eyebrows yes yes
you look kind of just like tough but
now we're over here oh man this you guys
this is so sick
again getting more subtle here you know
really like dialing in that face
I don't know how uh reveal like I want
to be with my facial features now just
like yeah I kind of have a big face yeah
my eyebrows kind of sit kind of low
but I mean literally you how
many options just starting the game I
feel like I'm going to be here like
forever yeah you and me both and then
this this final tab here this is where
you kind of bring your whole character
together you know this is where you
finalize everything you're not choosing
your house here okay that's not yet that
was a theory uh but but you know here's
where you bring uh you choose voice one
or voice two which is more kind of a
masculine or a feminine voice and then
even within that changing your pitch a
pitch slider it's a subtle slider but
yeah but you can hear it about that was
quite something and so you can kind of
make out the differences but yeah you
choose which kind of voice that you want
uh you'll be selecting your difficulty
here for today we'll just go normal
because Andrew's going to be uh taking
us through some of the experiences with
combat later and we can talk a little
more about difficulty yeah with with
combat and how that plays in but but I
think the important thing here is like
if if for people who aren't Gamers
especially right story mode is a way to
get into this without being worried
about like oh do I need to be good at
games like no just enjoy this game and I
would put expecto and then go
very good awesome and then uh whether
you want to be witch or wizard
amazing what do you think character
creator we're good I'm good I'll let yo
let's explore Hogwarts and let's get
into some all right through the magic of
uh using using a dev kit we're gonna be
loading up a save a little later in
um so that we can show you more about
Hogwarts and give you that taste of
combat all right Andrew's got some
gameplay pulled up for us here we are uh
starting out James there there you are
you're wearing the house fanatic robes
uh from the from the account linking
thank you thank you I I do look good and
this is our first look at the Hufflepuff
common room I'm assume I mean dorm room
dorm room yeah yeah this is awesome but
Alan what are we seeing right here with
the UI because this is our first look
yeah so um right now we know there's
been a lot of questions about uh
about about the HUD because this is the
first time we're showing it so um kind
of going over from right to left on the
bottom right is what we call Our Spell
Diamond so those are everything that you
see in it are slottable spells so we
have over 20 slatable spells that you
can earn over the course of the game
okay and and that's where the player can
place them and use them and access them
very quickly
um to the top left of that is you'll see
the d-pad and on the left is an eyeball
and on the right is a bit of a grid so
the eyeball is an example of one of not
a slottable spell but what we call an
essential spell there are certain spells
that are used in very specific contexts
or or that we just want on the
controller at all times and ravello is
one of those that's left on the d-pad on
the right on the d-pad is that grid
represents where you might slot spells
and so okay right now today we're not
going to be going into the spell
slotting menu because we feel like
there's a lot of spoilers there you know
like what are all the Spells and what
can we do
but we do want to make sure there's
still some goodies left to share with
everyone and then on the left side that
thing that has the one button next to it
that's another thing where we don't want
to spoil but basically that's where you
access your tool wheel so there's a lot
of magical tools that you're going to be
uh kind of brewing and growing over the
course of the game and so that's where
you would access them rapidly is our two
wheel okay cool um there are a few
things that I left off the table on the
right uh the green bar is your health
and basically there's a potion next to
it that's how you might heal the bar
above it we're keeping a secret for now
I apologize and uh all the way on the
left is our mini-map with a kind of
overhead view of where you are currently
in your common room that updates as you
travel through Hogwarts and Beyond out
into the world and for those those fans
out there that aren't a huge fan of
Minnie Mouse because we know they exist
there's also options to remove the
mini-map and turn on or off different
elements of our HUD if you immerse
yourself yeah and yeah and we'll go more
into the Spells as we get into combat
but that's kind of that's that's what
you're seeing there and this is is our
HUD also Andrew's giving us a good look
over here I want to I want to call out
uh I'm a big fan of the bedside tables
in the dormitories
um
very nice bedside tables bedside tables
yeah the honey colored wood was
mentioned in the writing it's part of
Lord it's part of Laura there we go all
right so now we're walking out into
we we really tried making these low
ceiling dorms to give you that Badger
set yeah sort of feel the first thing I
know is the music the score is amazing
with this gorgeous and I'm calling out
here uh this is unique music that you're
hearing for the Hufflepuff common room
go back to those common Room videos we
released you'll notice the music's a
little bit different and that is
entirely intentional
we just want to welcome you to your
common room in every single house just a
little bit differently so you can
customizing that experience right away
oh my gosh it's so awesome look at that
so I mean beautiful design I I we could
spend like the entire rest of the stream
just in the common room here and talking
about it and I'm sure Boston and James
could be like just geeking out over here
this all the details come from JK
Rowling's writings for this common room
the round doors the hanging Vines even
the dancing Badgers on the tires yeah
it's very very earthy which is which is
like elements for each of the houses
right like this earth ravenclaws air
gryffindor's fire and Slytherin is water
we really really leaned into that for
each common room wow so it feels earthy
we've got a little Earth and passageway
that's that's what we were hopefully it
should feel very familiar yeah yeah it
does it does but I I know you don't want
to leave but we're going to be leaving
thank you I understand
whoa the sound effects though like
looking back at the past trailers it was
just music but kind of hearing how
Hogwarts is now that's so cool it's
tactile yeah Andrew's gonna make use of
one of our spells rebellio is revelio
right here because there's a little
magic going on
so
um these are something that we kind of
interchangeably call revelo Pages or
lore pages and you'll notice a bunch of
things pop up on the screen yeah you see
that we got some XP for it and you can
also see that we've Advanced something
called like a field guide challenge so I
want to talk about that a little bit so
we had to ask ourselves what
I'm sorry there may be something you may
or may not be able to tickle that yeah
but uh in our game we had to answer the
question you know we're a late fifth
year what does that mean how do we catch
up to the other students okay okay so we
have an answer to that question and and
it's given to you by the staff so
there's something that we call the
Wizards Field Guide that's granted to
you early on in the game and the Wizards
Field Guide is how how you actually work
on catching up with the other students
so Andrew if you hit pause for me up
here before you push forward a little
bit you can see in our pause menu It's
Got This Book theme wow that's your
Wizard's Field Guide and you can see
your house kind of crazy okay
you can see that on your level as well
so that the field guide has this magical
property of looking out into the world
around you and the reason why it's on
loan from the ministry of magic and the
professors have granted it to you as a
late fifth year student is because they
want it to help you catch up to the
other kids and its magical property is
to discover different opportunities to
learn and grow all around you so the way
it works is as you discover gameplay in
the game it actually recognizes that as
a challenge which is kind of locked into
there and Andrew if you go in there
you'll see different types of challenges
that are combat challenges Quest
challenges exploration challenges and
you can see Field Guide pages are on
there as well yeah
that one feel bad page that entire
category is one of the ways that the
book itself kind of fills out into the
school and Spills out into the school
and kind of hides itself with different
types of challenges and different things
to do around the school that you're
actually going to interact with to help
you grow as a wizard and practice your
spells and so that thing that we just
saw is not just a field guide Challenge
and a way to earn XP it's also something
that that players can use to learn about
the school as they're traveling around
they spot these little secret facts and
they can kind of play a little bit of a
game discovering all of them and their
their over 100 Field Guide Pages just in
Hogwarts alone a little glimpse of the
grand staircase here
circular circuits all the portraits and
I did notice the flu flame just ignite
right there which was so cool yeah oh
man fast travel points there house
hourglasses we had to I how much fun was
it designing those and putting all those
gorgeous but but they're just like in
the books yeah right to the Great Hall
is the non-to-lord house points is not a
core mechanic or system in the game it
is we narrowed it into like a gameplay
system but it's definitely present
throughout our narrative and and there
are lots of choices where we want to nod
to things that aren't aren't necessarily
gameplay systems but yeah but we nod to
them as as part of the narrative over to
the right
Andrew was teasing that's the Great Hall
over through those doors again we're not
going there where he's just kind of like
cool cool
uh here's another collectible page you
know just again showing you like just
these things around Hogwarts that you
can do and pick up and
that's a shot straight from the trailer
too it's that part right there I I
recognize that might be giving you a
little fan service here with uh with
callbacks to those so and this must be
summertime because I noticed these are
the summertime Windows these windows
will change with the seasons yeah the
detailing point of this is kind of it I
get surprised by it all the time
oh man
and we're going out
look at that this is where the students
would normally kind of congregate just
to kind of chill out play meet each
other outside the Great Hall before and
after meals
and I I love the way that when the
castle interconnects to uh that it
interconnects outside inside their their
pathways on both sides of things so you
really get a sense of scope to how big
this Castle is when you see things like
you you'll notice a bridge over there
that's a place you can go to and cross
like everything is everything that you
see is a place that you can visit wow we
tried so we put a lot of effort and make
it feel really alive not just with
student population but even just the
greenery and stuff it's Scotland yeah
and this Castle has been here for
hundreds of years so just kind of the
Moss and all the trees that have
overgrown it and oh my gosh that
landscape that Scottish might look a
little familiar to you um I thought I
recognized it I believe this is from the
spring ASMR and yes so that puzzle right
there that view uh Andrew is taking us
right back I'm going to tell Andrew not
to interact with that puzzle and to keep
moving on
no we can't spoil everything we can't
give you everything right Hogwarts
contains a lot of Secrets
but this is this Grand entryway right
here coming down into uh really kind of
Central Area yeah we're coming upon the
central Hall and we pointed out the
green house outside and and we'll notice
when we get down there that it's on the
right
this is a big Hub of the school like
it's a big castle but
um it is designed so you shouldn't get
very lost this is kind of a Grand
Central Station I love that each
Direction you know it's green over there
so the greenhouse is over there
Transfiguration Courtyard you know the
library straight ahead so it's kind of a
The Hub oh my God a lot of the castle
even the color visually you could just
tell okay green green
oh my God I should a lot of it will be
subconscious but it'll help you really
feel learn the castle and feel like you
know your way around
that's that's not to say that it's easy
to learn all of us here still get pretty
lost in it daily basis it's a castle
it's a great point
I love that Andrew's uh definitely
teasing a lot of things here I'm
noticing he's swinging the camera this
way and that is
yeah he's got this grin on his face over
there that's just like yeah
that Dragon oh my God that's another
location where the students will gather
um you know and just kind of chill out
and an opportunity to uh talk to
somebody get a get a quest Giver here
is everything all right yes I'm sorry
I'm just I'm Nelly by the way I'm just
so excited that the daily and keys are
back the what keys the dedalian keys
surely you've seen them flying about
rumor is that a former headmistress
Professor mole conjured them to protect
the contents of certain locked cabinets
years ago Professor black couldn't be
bothered to disenchant the Keys and they
appear every few years you should try to
catch one
why would I do that each key will lead
you to a locked cabinet somewhere in the
castle if you can manage to get the key
into the cabinet lock not an easy task
you may find a reward
perhaps I'll give it a go I hope you do
in fact I think I heard one of the keys
in the astronomy Tower you should listen
for them
this is kind of side quests are really
it's a cool way to interact with your
fellow students with perhaps other
teachers with you know various things
like that as well as teach you some more
of the secrets of Hogwarts I think
there's there's in this case absolutely
yeah so the students are a way to kind
of like flesh out the school
opportunities around it what what we can
do and then those interactions uh
different interactions with different
characters can also offer different
Choice points for the player and then
some of those things can can affect
things game wide some of these affect
characters lives uh the ending of the
game
um and sometimes it's just about you
being a little bit just being a jerk
so the scale really varies but but uh
but those opportunities exist for the
player wow look at this
this is the Dada defense against the
dark arts the power power which this is
one of my favorite locations in
in the castle just visually you come in
here and just the the richness of this
area very unique to
anywhere else in the castle somebody
else that we can talk to uh notably a
younger student yeah she looks like a
first year or an 11 year old
are you all right don't you know who I
am
zenobian Oak the girl whom everyone at
school hates for no reason
everyone hates you
why because Hogwarts is full of bullies
and spoil Sports Leander Pruitt's one of
the worst that no Talent Moon mind I
wanted to make some new friends and so I
bought my collection down to the common
room my gobstone collection that is
I was hoping someone would want to play
are you familiar with gobstones little
balls like marbles Grand game and if you
lose they spray you with a foul-smelling
liquid
foreign
I haven't much interest in a game that
sprays you with odors only if you lose
which I never do or at least not often
people can be so cruel
just because they're sprayed all over
with smelly gobstones spit it's their
own fault for losing Imelda is one of
the worst losers ever written a story or
a terrible as well and now those poor
losers have taken my gobstones and
hidden them in very high places all over
the school
foreign
situation and they responded accordingly
I didn't make the
make them anyway
I can't work out how to get them back on
my own I don't think I know the
necessary spells yet
I need someone perhaps a selfless and
talented fifth year to help me
I'll see what I can do I don't
I did myself in no time
I love that interaction with her because
there's so many ways that you can go
with that you can like you can feel for
her you can be a jerk to her you can be
like a cop sound sounds awful it sounds
like you're just mean like oh yeah and
your opportunities to be mean there
aren't over yeah so they continue that's
a good example of the gobstones too I
know people are gonna ask gobstones
gobstone's playable they mentioned it
right yeah um so yeah uh gobstos is one
of the things that is not playable in
the game
um I know we've we've had to rip the
Band-Aid off on a few things I honestly
it's both a it's an amazing thing on the
franchise how many things about this
like like speak to us as fans and that
we want to turn into gameplay and and
there were calls that we had to make
over the course of production of kind of
like which things we will and won't
include in the Bible just kind of for
the overall Wizards chess those are
things that aren't featured aren't
featured they're featured within the
world I'm glad they're mentioned they're
a part of the Wizarding World yeah every
single time there was something that we
we regretted because we we couldn't
include it we also tried to figure out a
way to make sure it was included in the
narrative included in the stories make
sure that there's a way to kind of like
acknowledge it touch it you know and
make it feel like it's definitely part
of the world
and I know here too
I was like where in this music is dark
arts past I recognize that staircase to
the left where we were just at Andrews
walking by I also recognized the dragon
at the very top oh my gosh being in a
classroom I think this is a good
opportunity to talk about how classes
work because we've gotten a lot of
questions about that is it a schedule
based system is it to tell us how
classes work yeah so um ultimately
decided not to go the Sim route so I
think like one of the speculations was
is there a time of day and you know that
kind of thing like can I miss class at
this time of day there is a gay night
cycle yeah yeah there's a day night
cycle but uh but everything is very um
narrative based and so there's a big
mystery going on in the world there's
something happening in the narrative and
we and we essentially see it as kind of
like chapters in that narrative each
chapter of which has a set of missions
that you can choose between as you're
progressing through the game and classes
fit within that structure so there are
Mainline things the players have to do
and then and classes also appear on the
sides as well as optional things that
help you advance your spells it's
absolutely true that classes provide all
of your major tools throughout the
gameplay your spells your major
abilities you get to know the professors
each one of them has these bespoke kind
of events moments and those missions and
then there are also additional
opportunities outside of that through
kind of like side classroom missions
essentially where you can learn
additional spells or things that you
need in your adventure and also get to
know the professors better
and I just want to call out something
that Andrew's been kind of showing off
ways to kind of interact with the
environment and just just engage with
the world and you know maybe down there
who's sipping some tea
Victorian Heist you know yeah High
Society I just no wonder you like this
area because we built it for like the
pure blood to the slytherins
well like speaking of lived in like the
sound effects again the chatter of the
communication that's happening and the
footsteps like it just makes it feel
more alive little events like that yeah
the data Tower was one example but um no
two hallways should look the same in
Hogwarts it's a it has a lot of
Personality every hallway should be a
little bit different and that's mostly
to help Orient the players right right
help you not get lost but uh this is
Hesperus Hall that's a little nod from
the Marauders a name that came from the
Marauders map but every hallway will
have a little bit of a different
personality and
personality I like that because it gives
it does like Hogwarts has character
Hogwarts is its own character no matter
where you go
feels just a little bit different yeah
sentient Castle full of magic for
hundreds of years it's going to kind of
grow and develop oh I heard something
yeah speaking of characters speaking of
magic Mr Magic himself
you know we talked about building on
lore too I know there's that statue over
to the side that's you know who that is
Lachlan the lanky and he's got his
bowtruckle friend and and I think if
players don't know there's another page
there yeah there's a map of argyle sure
we know the fat lady hides there hides
behind it that's right third butt but
sometimes a hallway has personality by
how it looks or we just passed a music
hallway where the portraits have kind of
taken it over and
um so the sound makes it really unique
all right I gotta call this out here I
know there's been some criticism in the
past that uh our trailer is our game
plan what we've shown so far has not had
enough owls okay so here we are at the
allery we're looking directly at the
allery to show you all of the owls
everything else it's a lot of hours I
love the fog rolling down now great
callback great call no I also I also
love that as I I one of my favorite
things about just kind of going around
on the outside of the school is that all
those things that I see are places that
I can go to that I can visit I just love
that sensation knowing that that is real
that lovely Scottish Countryside we're
kind of closing out our our mini tour of
Hogwarts and again but a fraction of uh
this enormous Castle
we're closing it out here in the Clock
Tower so another recognizable location
but this is where crossed wands which is
the secret not so secret dueling Club is
uh that the students have put together
professors definitely know about it but
they think they're being clever uh and
it's run by this Luke and bradleby here
who's in a younger year but we kind of
like that this that he's running things
hello Lucan may I use the training dummy
of course I'll fetch it and give you a
list of combinations to practice ready
to have a try now
that would be wonderful be sure to cast
all your spells before the dummy lands
if you need to stop practicing before
you finish all of them let me know this
is a really good opportunity to now jump
into combat because really in the game
this is going to be uh the first time
where you yourself get to learn about
combat and combos in a big way and in a
new way for me personally this is where
the game like really starts to open up
to the possibilities uh
so we've set up uh We've set up a
training dummy and this is kind of an
activity where you're supposed to
execute according to kind of the
iconography on the top now uh what we
say on the top is the accio spell
followed by for what we just kind of
lovingly refer to as basic shots there's
spells with the Wizards kind of like use
just kind of fling Andrew's using one
now
and you trigger that by tapping R2 on
your controller so you can see in the
corner R2 so if you tap R2 that throws
out a basic shot but that R2 is also
your gateway to all of the the spells
that you might slot so if you hold R2
instead you can see how the diamond
expands and if we let go you see how it
contracts yeah and so if you hold it
again it expands and so when it expands
and all the spells that you slotted
while you're holding that button can now
be tapped with your face buttons awesome
and not only that but over the course of
the game you can gain
um additional spell diamonds up to four
additional ones so that you can slot up
to 16 spells you know pretty much
instantly and then that helped us
fulfill the fantasy of in combat I need
to be able to access things very rapidly
yeah and and so you learn over the
course of these events you know how to
juggle not just the spell casting but
also it reinforces an understanding of
another feature of the wheel which is
their cooldowns so as you're casting
spells just to make sure that you're not
just kind of like repeatedly using one
thing over and over again you can see
cooldowns on the spells that he's using
uh on the wheel and then as you progress
through the game there are different
things that can affect things like cool
Downs through your talents uh different
things that allow you to kind of like
juggle and adjust and update those
things and so if you hold down our R2
and you tap the d-pad it will switch
between your other diamonds if you've
unlocked them and and that's how you
access all those oh man
looks like you're about to get some
action over here
yeah
so this is this is a great way to kind
of learn how to
pull things together
um
together yeah
accio tap tap tap awesome
and that's just against the dummy but I
mean uh uh
[Music]
thank you looking I say better to
discover one's weaknesses during
practice than during a duel
you'll be a fearsome Challenger now
I think now we can uh we can take on
something a little more challenging it's
going to shoot back uh now let's talk
about uh some more features of the
combat system
hello Lucan is the next round of cross
the ones all said ah yes it is I've
just lined up
we're on a PS5 dev kit here so we're
going to be able to kind of pause the
pause the action and talk about what
you're seeing on the screen because
there's about to be a lot going on okay
okay um
[Music]
all right here you can select if you
want to fight with somebody else some of
your questions yeah but in this case
we're not we want we want that action to
feel a little more frantic towards you
to really get you that sense of of uh of
combat
so apparently you've uh got quite the
reputation because they've got you up
against three yeah off the Jump
yeah
um so I can I can explain this uh just
because I know people are going to go
into it but we can probably just kind of
jump in
um so uh you're not the only one that
has protego and the ability to deflect
the enemies do too and we actually play
with that when it comes to the spell
casting so you notice that there are
different colored kind of shields around
the different characters and you'll also
notice that your spells have different
colors on them so to help players
understand kind of like the function of
their spells we're trying to put them
into brackets so there are damaged
spells there are four spells there are
freaking in the other one all the
control spells and so those things for
the player they wind up also being a
color indicator for which which actual
spell to use to break the different
Shields that enemies can use that way it
rewards kind of like that close
attention that you're paying paying on
things we've got this paused here now
and you can kind of see all the elements
on the screen the the halo around the
Avatar's head each of the different
shields uh to kind of give us give us a
breakdown of what's going to break down
different things that you're saying
um so you notice at the top uh that
we're we're kind of like calling out
which enemy you currently have targeted
and their level and health and so you
know as you target different characters
you'll be able to get that breakdown the
uh the halo over your head whenever an
enemy is about to an attack it's it's
almost like you have a little bit of a
sixth sense for those things that are
coming
um if you see the Halo it means there's
an incoming attack and if you tap the
triangle button by default then that
you'll be able to deflect that attack
that comes in and I love that deflector
it goes off and and like hits things up
and kind of breaks things off walls too
but also uh if you hold the button then
it doesn't just it doesn't just deflect
it also deflects and turns around with a
counter attack Stupify that actually
stuns the enemy and you can use that
even in your Combos and stuff so if
you're focused on a character you know
and you're you're doing your thing and
someone else attacks you you can
actually turn that attack into the
director attack on the person that
you're comboing back into into gameplay
here Andrew's gonna
pretty pretty handily finished these
these other students off here is win
this dude how fast it is
like a dance
yeah we really felt like the uh we
really felt like in the movies there's
almost like a
[Music]
kind of like a there's this element of
kind of like fencing from a very great
distance that's a good call and there
are a lot of uh a lot of things that we
had to do with with our controls and
combat system in order to kind of
capitalize on that idea yeah that's
pretty unique to The Wizarding World
well perhaps you should try that next
time
they're the Duelists have already taken
notice of you but after that last round
they'll really have it in for you you'd
better keep practicing if you want a
chance of winning or at least surviving
the next round
I'll let you know when we're ready hope
to see you then
the next round is for all the gobstones
so to speak
and that is more or less gonna wrap it
up for us for now for what we want to
show you character creator tour of
Hogwarts and uh just that that little
taste of combat uh but we we didn't want
to leave you without maybe a little
taste of something that that we're uh we
may show in the future may show next
time uh
you know so leaving the castle
uh going out here
[Music]
more and more owls uh
owl mail there's the owlry again yes all
of the owls
but yeah just heading out here again to
show you like from Hogwarts to the world
Beyond Hogwarts and
this is not somewhere where we're going
today but we'll we will definitely be
taking you in the future
oh
a little Glimpse that the the scale of
the castle back there
all right so we're going to wrap things
up here but uh I I hope you guys have
enjoyed everything that you've seen but
I think James you may have a few other
questions here at the end of things so
while we're done with uh what we're
showing on the gameplay side uh I know
there's a few things that you want to
pick Alan and Boston's brains about I
would love that because there's a lot
all right so
um some of these questions we did pull
from the community uh secretly but I did
fall for the community so uh and also
from I mean going through this I feel
like they're they're yeah you've come up
with some things you want to talk a
little more about I'm sure elaborate on
because we went through character
customization Hogwarts itself and even
combat so uh this would be like for the
both of you guys uh will we be able to
go back and change our character
creation if we don't like it
um so not everything but there are
certain things uh with hairstyle hair
color uh so kind of like core shapes you
know like with the body and face not
after the fact okay but there are lots
of things there's kind of like a barber
shop in hogsmeade that you can go to and
of course right yeah you could change
your hair color for
holidays or something oh my gosh that
would be so cool the game features a lot
of
um appearance customization in it so
there's there's a ton of options there
um but that's that's in terms of like
your character and stuff that you have
the Character Creator it's like a it's
like a a smaller set of what you saw
there okay oh my gosh awesome awesome
next question what kind of leisurely
activity can we do uh can we study with
our free time I mean what we'll be doing
just hanging out in Hogwarts um because
uh as you progress to the game there's a
bunch of different missions that open up
most of them are driven by different
characters personalities you know some
of them want help getting up to hijinks
or they want some of them want to just
explore secrets in the castle because
there are new secrets in our Castle to
explore and so
um so I think uh there's there's a bunch
of things to do and when it comes to
class
um as I mentioned earlier it's not just
kind of like the mainline stuff they're
kind of like extracurricular assignments
some of which are optional some of which
are are kind of like uh blockers for
main mission kind of like you can't go
on this mission right until you have the
spell and then the spell is open you
know the assignment and how you complete
it yeah with with your professor and so
there are opportunities to
um to study so to speak like with that
right but they're really they do all
take take uh the form of our mission
structure as you mentioned earlier wow
um let's get into some combat right
quick uh do spells have different levels
or are they all equal
Bells have different levels or are they
all equal I'm trying to think of how to
describe that so each spell has kind of
like its own core identity and what it
does in the game uh with regards to both
kind of like puzzling World exploration
and and enemy combat and all that kind
of stuff and then it's through the
talent system okay right okay when you
go into that it's kind of like each of
those spells has ways to kind of like
advance and grow and change and as you
spend talents in some cases it even
changes like the way you approach the
the battlefield and things like that so
I I'd say that's no more true than with
like dark arts for example and as you go
down that line and you kind of play
around with those talents it really does
start to kind of like affect even how
you approach combat and how you think
about the battlefield
I won't be touching the dark art stuff
but I know many of you guys will be
maybe on your second thing yeah the
second play through yes dark Hufflepuff
coming hashtag soon
um I want to close off with this
question and I this is before everybody
and we'll start with Boston
um
with this game that you guys have been
working on for however long and the
excitement you guys have what's one
aspect of Hogwarts Legacy that you are
excited for the fans to experience
Boston I think I am just excited for the
fans to play through the world
specifically the castle and uh maybe go
read those books again
I I hope that either whether you're
already a fan
and you know love this game or this is
your first introduction into the world I
I hope they just point at each other in
the best way possible and
um I'm just excited for fans to get to
finally go to Hogwarts and feel like
they can own it and live there I've
lived there for five years it's a great
place to live official fifth year
I uh it it's it's really funny because
because I my I want to give a different
answer and I will but but I actually
feel like the most honest answer is
really similar
um because my favorite thing when you
know when running around playing the
game and getting to know you know
Hogwarts the way Boston knows it because
she knows the school and the lore better
than I do and thank God right because
you want the person architecting it to
really know that yeah but um when I when
I re-watch the films or or I'm rereading
passages from the books there's a
different relationship to those things
having played the game right and so it's
really looking over the edge and seeing
seeing location I'm like oh my God I'm
right there and in the movie saying I
know what's around that corner in the
film like if you go down this way yeah
there's actually a thing over here and
there's this person over here and this
thing happened and it just adds all this
richness to everything that you already
love and not just that you're going to
add your own story yeah so you know what
happens around that corner because you
did something yeah yeah and then the the
quick answer just you have something
different is I just love being on a
broom I just love looking at the whole
world and just being like okay I can
just go there at Vantage Point yeah it's
there's just something exhilarating
about it that feels very different in
that kind of open air and on that thing
it just like it's kind of incredible
yeah
and and wrapping it up uh you know for
me it's just bringing the community
together with it and sharing those
stories because it is your story and you
you are going to be writing you know
this is this is your unique experience
within this and even within the things
that are the same it's going to be your
unique experiences different from mine
is different from we're all approaching
it from different places and I think
that's going to be really cool the way
that everybody brings those things
together all right and that's everything
that we have to show you today I know
maybe it wasn't everything you wanted to
see but it was a whole lot of stuff
character creator uh uh a little mini
tour of Hogwarts there just a small part
of it a little bit of combat
um and we've we do have some more stuff
coming up for you in the future Hogwarts
Legacy releases on February 10 2023 and
is available for pre-order now but
that's going to do it from us we're
going to leave you with a little
something else but for now uh
bye bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]